now to myanmar where the military junta
has leveled fresh charges against
deposed leader aung sang
chi accusing her of accepting illegal
payments were six hundred thousand
dollars
and gold while in power so far they've
produced no evidence to back up the
charges
meanwhile at least six people have been
killed in myanmar on thursday
after security forces fired on them
during demonstrations
they were in the town of miang taking
part in protests against last month's
military coup
which overthrew aung sang-su chi's
government
there are also reports that at least one
other person has been
killed in the country's largest city
yangon his latest violence comes after
the u.n security council demanded the
military
restore democratic control it is
absolutely essential
to respect the result of the elections
and to allow for a situation in which
we move back to a democratic transition
let's get
more from journalist andrew knackerson
who joins us from
yangon uh welcome andrew um let's start
with
those deaths in me and ma in in myang
and yangon that followed just hours
after anton antonio guterres made that
speech
yeah well so we've heard that there have
been protests in
myang plenty of times since the coup
this is the first time that we know of
that they've opened fire with deadly
force
there's obviously been other deaths in
yangon before but it all feels kind of
random like
the junta just on some days tells
security forces
that they can go out and kill people and
i guess the intention is to
give all protesters the impression that
any day they go out they could be killed
and the military says it only uses
force where necessary and as far as we
can see watching the
the the tv uh clips
the protesters are peaceful so what's
your assessment
yeah i i think that's just flatly not
true
um like you said the overwhelming
majority of the protesters have been
totally peaceful unarmed we've seen
you know teenagers young women
shot in the head it really doesn't
reflect what the tamil is saying about
only using force when necessary they
seem to use force
totally indiscriminately
now the the country's uh former civilian
leader she's facing new allegations that
seem
much more significant than the the the
two charges she faced before
yeah the these are the big charges um
she had been charged for some kind of
kind of silly things before um violating
coven 19 restrictions
illegally importing walkie-talkies i
think these were kind of placeholder
charges
while they tried to dig up something a
little more serious
um corruption charges have seen people
sentenced to
prison for as long as 30 years so i
think these are the charges that they're
really hoping are going to
permanently sideline ongoing tsuchi from
politics
right and what are they saying that she
has done
well like you said they they haven't
offered us a ton of details they said
she accepted illegal payments
six hundred thousand dollars in cash and
gold um
they said the information came from the
nld's
chief minister in yangon um but all we
have so far is the military's word
meanwhile uh the the shooting continues
and
the protesting uh continues and
no one seems to be giving way yeah i
mean
the the taping seems to really be
digging their heels in they haven't
responded very well to any suggestions
for
diplomacy or dialogue and i think the
nld side kind of feels like
they shouldn't have to negotiate or make
any concessions because they won an
election in an overwhelming landslide so
under what normal circumstances would
the winning party have to
make any concessions um so both sides
seem quite far apart all right thanks
for joining us
andrew knackerson in yangon